hello i'm mathias and the founder of
datatab
in this video i will explain in a simple
way everything about the t-test for
independent samples
and how you can easily calculate the
t-test online with data tab
let's start from scratch there are three
variants
of the t-test the simple t-test the
independent t-test
and the dependent t-test the simple
t-test
is used to check whether there is a
difference between a group
and the population this t-test is very
often used in quality assurance
for example to check whether a produced
screw
really has the given weight on average
the independent t-test is used to check
whether there is a difference between
two independent samples for example
there is a difference between the salary
of men and women
the t-test for dependent samples is used
to test
whether there is a difference between
two dependent samples
for example samples where a person was
interviewed
at two different times this video is
about the t-test for independent samples
in the description of this video you
will find links to my videos and
tutorials about the other t-tests
now you may ask yourself what is the
difference between an independent
and independent sample independent
samples are made up
of independent persons and measurements
a person in this group has no
relation to a person in this group they
are two completely
separated groups therefore independent
samples
result from independent persons or
measurements
for dependent samples the measured
values are available
in pairs the pairs result for example
from repeated measurements
with the same person therefore this
person is the same person
as this person this video is about the
independent t-test
so we consider independent samples but
what do i need
the independent t test for let's say we
want to check
if there's a difference between two
groups and the population
for example if there's a difference in
salary between men
and women of course it is not possible
to ask
all men and women for the salary so
we take a sample in order to be able to
make
statement about the population based on
this sample
we need the independent t test therefore
we need the independent t test
to make a statement about the population
based
on the sample the question for the
independent thesis is therefore
is there a statistically significant
difference between the mean value
of two groups possible questions could
be
is there a difference between people
with and without studies with regard
to their health or do two production
lines produce
screws with the same weight or
do smokers have a higher risk of heart
attack than non-smokers
in order to calculate the independent
t-test the hypothesis must first
be defined from the research question
this is our assumption about the reality
whose validity is possible but not yet
proven
there are always two hypotheses the
so-called
null hypothesis and the alternative
hypotheses
the null hypothesis assumes that there's
no
difference between two groups with
respect to a certain
characteristics for example the salary
of men and women does not
differ in germany in contrast the
alternative hypothesis
however assumes that there is a
difference between two groups
for example the salary of men and women
differ in germany further we distinguish
whether a hypothesis is directed
or undirected this plays a major role in
the interpretation of the results at the
end
first of all what is an undirected and
what is undirected hypotheses
undirected hypotheses test whether there
is a difference
whereby it does not matter in which
direction
the connection of the difference goes
for example
there is a difference between the salary
of men and women
but it is not mentioned in which
direction if the salary of men is higher
as if from roman or the other way around
or
there is a difference in heart attack
risk between smokers and non-smokers
but it doesn't tells us in which
direction it goes
two smokers have a higher or a lower
heart attack risk
in contrast there are the directed
hypotheses
these hypotheses also indicate the
direction
of the difference for example men earn
more than women
or smokers have a higher risk of heart
attacks
than non-smokers so let's come to the
next section the requirements
there's an independent variable for
example the gender
which has two characteristics or groups
for example
male and female this is important you
only can have
two groups you cannot calculate in
t-test with three or more groups
these two groups should be compared in
the analysis
the question is thus is there a
difference between the two groups
regarding to the dependent variable for
example the income
we have these four requirements the two
groups or samples must be
independent the variables must be scaled
in intervals the variables must be
normally distributed
and the variance within the groups
should be similar
now we will have a look at all of these
four requirements and details
the first one the two groups or samples
must be independent
as the name of the t-test suggested the
samples must be independent
this means that a value in a one sample
must not influence a value in the other
sample
this is for filled for example if you're
measuring the weight of people who have
been on a diet
and people who have not been on a diet
but it is not fulfilled
if you're measuring the right of a
person before and after a certain diet
because then you have the same person
and have the measurement before
and after the diet from this same person
and then we have a dependent sample the
next requirement is that the variables
must be scaled
in intervals for the t test for
independent samples
the mean value of the sample must be
calculated
this is only meaningful if the variables
is interval
scaled for example the weight of a
person
not valid would be the educational level
of a person
secondary modern school higher school
and so on and so forth
the third requirement is the variable
must be normally distributed
the t-test for independent samples gives
the most accurate results
when the data from each group are
normally distributed
this requirement is fulfilled for
example for the weight
the age was a high of a person it is not
fulfilled
for example for the number after
throwing it dies
the fourth requirement is that the
variance within the groups should be
similar
since the variance is needed for the
test statistic t
it must be the same variance within the
groups
for example the weight the h or the
height of a person
not valid would be the stock price
normal times and in the recession
so how can we calculate the t test for
independent samples
they are two different equations we must
consider
if we have equal variance or unequal
variance
the task is to compare if these two
groups have the same
mean value before calculating the t-test
we must know if these two groups
has equivariance or unequal variance
how it can now be checked if the
variance is equal or not
this is where the levine test helps the
levine test checks whether several
samples have the same variance the
levine test checks
whether several samples have the same
variance
if the p-value in the levine test is
greater than 0.05
variances equality can be assumed
otherwise variance equality cannot be
assumed
let's start how we can calculate the t
test for independent
samples for unequal variances let's
imagine we have these two groups
group 1 and group 2 and we want to
compare
the mean value the t value can then be
calculated
with a mean wizard the t value can then
be calculated
with the mean of the first group and the
mean of the second group
divided by of the standard deviation of
the mean value difference
this value results with this equation
where n1
is the sample size of the first group
and n2
is the sample size of the second group
sp
can be calculated with this equation if
we combine all these equations
the t value can be calculated with this
formula or
a statistic program like data tab will
do it for you
further we need the degree of freedoms
which can be calculated
by the sample size of the first group
plus the sample size of the second group
minus 2. together with the t value and
the degree of freedom
we can calculate now the p-value or
the statistic software will calculate
the p-value for you
now we will have a look how you can
calculate the t-test for
independent samples if we have equal
variance
we have group 1 and group 2 both groups
have the same
variance and we want to know if the mean
value in both groups
is the same the t value can be
calculated with this equation
so we have the mean value of the first
group the mean value of the second group
we have the standard deviation of the
first group and we have the standard
deviation of the second group
and we have the sample size of the first
group and the sample size
of the second group further we need the
degree of freedom
and together with the degree of freedom
and the t value
we can calculate the p value or the
statistic software can do that for you
now you know how you can calculate the
d-value and the p-value
and now i'd like to show you how you can
easily calculate the t-test for
independent samples
online with data tab to do this please
visit
datatab.net and click on the statistics
calculator
here you can see this table if you want
to use your own data
please click on clear table and simply
copy your own data into this table
i will use the example data please copy
the names of the variables in the first
line because these names will appear
here
in the variable section we want to
calculate the t test
and therefore we click on t-test let's
imagine we want to compare
if the gender has an influence on the
salary
so we simply click on salary and
gender now data tab automatically
calculate
an unpaired t-test if the requirements
are not fulfilled you can also calculate
the non-parametric test the man with new
test but let's say
the requirements are fulfilled and we
can calculate the unpaired t-test
if you like you can check the conditions
here
at the beginning you will get the
descriptive statistics
of the two groups you will get the mean
value of the salary of men
and women and here you will get a box
plot
further you will get the results for the
levine test for variance equality
you can simply click on interpretation
and now you will get the interpretation
this results in a p-value of 0.09 which
is above the defined significance level
of 5
so the mean test is therefore not
significant and the null hypothesis
is confirmed thus there is an equality
of variance in the samples
so we calculate the t test for equal
variance
if we have a look in this table we will
go into this line
variances are equal and we can have a
look
at the p-value and the p-value is 0.056
so it is a little bit higher than our
significance level of 0.05
and therefore the null hypothesis is not
rejected
in this case the statement would be
there's no difference
between the salary of men and women
if you like you can simply click on
summary in words
the mail group had lower values for the
variable salary
than the female group the levine test of
variance equality has shown
that the variances equality can be
assumed
a t-test for independent samples showed
this difference was not statistically
significant so either you can simply
read the summary in words
or you can look at this table what the
p-value is
that is how easily you can calculate an
unpaired t-test
online with data tab now you know
what the unpaired t-test is and how you
can calculate it online with data tab
if you don't know data tab yet just
google data tab
on data tab you will find great
tutorials and you can analyze your data
directly online if you want to be
informed as soon as a new video of mine
is released
just subscribe to this channel bye
and see you soon